Emmanuel macón fue rápido para responder
Aunque el presidente francés dijo que no
subestima el descontento con la reforma
pensional de su gobierno rechazó la
solicitud de los sindicatos para una
reunión cara a cara argumentando que
había que respetar el debate en curso en
el parlamento sobre el proyecto
el parlamento seguirá los términos de
nuestra Constitución para que la
legislación pueda ser finalizada nada
más nada menos
un desaire que ha enfurecido los
sindicatos
los trabajadores van a tomar la
respuesta del presidente como un
desprecio porque él no escucha lo que
está sucediendo en las calles hay mucho
malestar Esta es una crisis social en un
momento de ruptura en el mundo del
trabajo las puertas cerradas del Eliseo
han sido el tema del momento en los
piquetes una falta de diálogo que podría
estimular acciones radicales de acuerdo
con estos trabajadores de una refinería
petrolera esto Solo empeorará la rabia
lo cual se traducirá o en una explosión
social en este país por las
movilizaciones o en una venganza
electoral en el futuro un presidente que
deja su primera ministra en primera
línea y recibe los golpes en un intento
por protegerse según este experto
político
es una manera de retirarse un poco y
escapar de la crítica pero no escapará
porque todo se reduce al presidente en
el panorama de los medios de hoy
discreción de parte de macron mientras
las cosas se mueven rápidamente esta
semana el senado votó a favor del
artículo bandera de la Reforma relativo
a la edad de retiro y la cámara baja del
parlamento debe votar la próxima semana
sin mayoría total en la asamblea
nacional Cómo podría optar porque los
cambios se concreten sin votar usando el
artículo 49.3 que permitiría que la
reforma se adopte directamente